What's next for the web-head as he heads back
into action and looks for things to return
to normal in his second MCU solo film?
We've got all the answers you're looking for
with this look at everything you need to know
before watching Spider-Man: Far from Home.
One of the most compelling things about Spider-Man:
Far from Home will be how Marvel chooses to
handle their first film after the incredibly
disruptive events of Avengers: Endgame.
Far From Home will definitely be more modest
in scale compared the cosmic events of Endgame,
Infinity War and Captain Marvel, Peter's going
to Europe, not space, but it can't ignore
the effects of the last two Avengers films.
Far from Home will be the first time Marvel
really shows us what the MCU looks like after
the Infinity Saga.
One of the biggest effects that Endgame had
on the MCU was a sudden jump five years into
the future.
Endgame co-directors Anthony and Joe Russo
have confirmed that the time jump means those
who were saved from Thanos' initial snap ended
up five years younger than everyone that had
survived.
It appears from the Spider-Man: Far from Home
trailers that many of Peter Parker's closest
friends and classmates still seem to still
be around the same age, which indicates that
they were probably all dusted together.
Best pals Ned and Peter, and apparently Mary
Jane were all snapped, and will consequently
still be the same age going into Far from
Home.
Perhaps the biggest can of worms that Endgame
opened up was the concept of time travel,
which inevitably leads to the multiverse.
It was already difficult to contain the effects
of time travel and the various branch realities
it creates within the plot of Endgame on its
own.
The alterations it can create could begin
to make MCU continuity start to feel a little
bit like herding cats.
Marvel's steering right into the skid, though.
"We could have used someone like you on my world."
"Your world?"
"Beck is from Earth. Just not ours."
The hard left into the multiverse concept
is impressive, but the question is, will it
hold up this many years into a universe that
has barely sniffed at any of these concepts
up until now?
And is Mysterio even telling the truth about
where he's from?
Historically, Quentin Beck has been a master
of illusion and misdirection, and Mysterio
is well-known as one of Spider-Man's classic
antagonists, even though the trailers are
clearly spinning him as more of a hero.
Common sense would dictate that the promotional
footage is simply warming up a character that
loves to fool others, and that he will ultimately
be revealed as a villain.
Marvel and Disney have become quite good at
promotional misdirects themselves, with multiple
trailers that have misled or outright lied
to fans.
When you consider that Marvel also basically
rewrote the entire script on the Skrulls in
Captain Marvel, flipping them from evil aliens
to sympathetic refugees, it makes the entire
Mysterio situation a bit of an enigma.
It's worth noting that the notion that Mysterio
has heroic aspirations is also seemingly a
sort of in-joke.
Jake Gyllenhaal, who plays Beck, came tantalizingly
close to taking over the role of Spider-Man
after Tobey Maguire sustained a back injury
between the first and second Sam Raimi-directed
films.
Mysterio crosses paths with Peter Parker because
of the looming threat of the Elementals, A
trio of destructive beings wreaking havoc.
They appear to be composed of water, fire
and earth.
According to a ScreenRant set report, Far
from Home will reveal the origins of these
additions to Spidey's rogues' gallery, and
there's also evidence to suggest that they're
tied in some way to the classic comics villains
Sandman, Molten Man, and Hydro-Man.
It's easy to assume that Mysterio is really
behind the whole thing, but however the story
ends up breaking down, Spider-Man will have
his webs full when it comes to bad guys this
time around.
There will never be another Tony Stark, but
it looks like the MCU is angling to have Spider-Man
fill an important need following Stark's death
in Endgame.
"I just really miss him."
"Yeah, I miss him, too."
Parker has typically been portrayed as a young
man both in print and onscreen, and the idea
of him looking up to a mentor or wanting to
impress other superheroes is hardly a new
concept.
In the MCU in particular, Iron Man has always
been the hero that has stood tallest in Parker's
eyes, beginning all the way back in Iron Man
2.
Parker is unlikely to ever become Iron Man...
"I'd rather just stay on the ground for a
little while.
Friendly neighborhood Spider-Man."
but it seems likely that he'll be called on
to step into the gap left by Stark's death.
The move would be a natural one, considering
their history, and would make for good storytelling
as Parker processes his loss and is faced
with some of the less savory elements of the
superhero life.
Far from Home promises to introduce several
new Spidey suits.
While we already know from the trailers that
we'll get to see the Iron Spider armor from
the Avengers films, there have also been hints
of upgrades to the more classic look, as well
as an entirely black stealth suit, a S.H.I.E.L.D.-inspired
outfit that takes quite a bit of inspiration
from the uniforms of past agents, including
Black Widow and Hawkeye.
Executive producer Eric Carroll explained
that, while the suit was originally pretty
high-tech, they ended up dumbing it down quite
a bit.
It was too high-powered, so the filmmakers
ended up making it, quote, "less cool" to
better fit Parker's character.
When you see him flipping up those goggles
by hand, know that it's absolutely on purpose.
Tom Holland's favorite thing about the suit?
It makes it a lot easier for the poor guy
to use the bathroom between takes.
Sony, not Marvel Studios, owns the rights
to Spider-Man, along with quite a few related
characters.
There was a harrowing moment in 1999 when
Marvel actually offered nearly all of its
existing characters to Sony for a paltry sum.
While Sony only nabbed the rights to Spidey
and friends, the webhead was still sorely
missed when the MCU took off in earnest.
"Underoos!"
In 2015, Sony and Marvel struck a unique shared-custody
deal that allowed Peter Parker to show up
in multiple MCU films while remaining a property
of Sony.
A lot about that deal remains unknown to the
public, with Vanity Fair having referred to
the arrangement as being, quote “densely
complicated.”
Some outlets have reported that the deal could
be up after Far from Home, which might leave
an interesting question mark at the end of
Parker's adventures abroad.
Will this be the last we see of the crime-fighting
spider in the MCU?
Is the current deal still going?
Or will Sony and Marvel hammer out a new agreement,
keeping the shared custody arrangement going
indefinitely?
The question is a big one, as it'll determine
whether Spidey will be an important part of
the MCU in the years to come, or if Far From
Home will be Tom Holland Spidey's swan song.
Spider-Man: Far from Home is the official
endcap for Phase 3 of the MCU, and it'll also
be the last time a Marvel movie is released
for nearly a year.
Far from Home swings into theaters on July
2, 2019, and the next Marvel movie won't be
released until May 1, 2020.
That's 304 days without a new Marvel movie,
the longest gap in quite some time.
"Parker, you're late, man!
Always late!"
The good news is, once the dust of Phase 3
finally settles, we're likely to get quite
a bit more info on what's coming.
The soon-to-launch Disney+ streaming service
will likely help fill in some of the gaps.
Fans who plan on subscribing should be able
to get a bit of a fix in some way or another,
whether that's through watching past Marvel
movies or indulging in the various MCU-related
limited series that Marvel is producing for
the platform.
But Far from Home is our last chance to enjoy
the MCU on the big screen for nearly a year,
so take advantage while you can.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Spider-Man
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.